before we say goodbye we want to play a
quick round up truth or dare
all right jackie schlein hi jackie
jackie slime
look how cute you look
very aligned bow blouse
i i styled after you tall that was the
plan oh my god
i know i could totally see you in that
hashtag twinning
cute all right what's it gonna be jackie
is it a truth or a dare i'm going to go
with the truth okay
okay so my question is what is the most
embarrassing text you've ever sent
one time i was put in charge of putting
together a dinner party with friends and
i invited everybody and i invited the
wrong people
and
and rather than tell them like oops i
didn't mean to invite you i just let
them come and guess what it was a huge
hit and now we're all friends
but oopsie my bad but it works
well
i like your text mishap
did you ever admit to any of them not
they're probably watching right now and
they have no idea it's them nope and uh
welcome to the family
all right well thank you so much
everybody for choosing to spend your
time with us we all make this show for
you so take it with you
[Music]